So how did I know the package I
wanted to install was called Finger?
Most of the time the package names
are pretty easy to guess, but
not all the time.
For instance Python has two
extremely popular versions,
you have Python 2 and Python 3.
It may be a bit more difficult to
figure out what the name of that
package would be.
Fortunately, each distribution tends
to publish an easy to browse version
of their repositories.
For Ubuntu, you can search for
packages at packages.ubuntu.com.
If I were to search for Python and
I look at this top result that says 2.7,
so that's Python version 2.
If I search for Python 3 and
I look at the top result it says 3.40,
so I know that's Python version 3.